ia a todos esta platéia faz tempo que eu
não vejo esta sala assim tão cheia mas
vamos aproveitar que o filme estava obra
tem thomas agradeço e vamos continuar cá
de maio junto vem pra fará o feto la num
saco como a farinha e uma mulher que é
vizinha de nuna hora procuramos todos os
mercados ajuda marli vai assumir momento
alguém com essa música então este tema
não é fácil
no séc eu imagino que no nosso
imaginário passado lância sempre que se
fala da palavra no séc
aquilo que nos faz pela cabeça seja
negativo não é é coisas agradáveis
erradas mas o fato é que quando nós
ouvimos essa música não é
ela traz o que traz coisas boas
vamos lá outra vez
mandei preparar um feto lá no meio só
que com boa farinha e moita carlos luna
ou a procura nos todos os mercados ajuda
marido vai assumir mesmo carro
cozinhe o feijão na velha panela de
barro só vai deixar o moisés neto vai
deixar ficar mal sabem já estamos em
conexão que era aquilo que eu criar esta
coisa boa está o ambiente tranquilo de
coisas boas de salvar as vezes não é
sempre que nós ouvimos a palavra no sec
e trazer esta idéia este desafio é facto
porque muitas vezes nos esquecemos
aquilo que aconteceu aqui há bocado que
é o prazer de nós cantaram zin lançaram
joão sexo como algo que seja bom então
vamos dar um minuto para vocês verem o
que se passa aqui que eu acho que isso
fábio de ontem que eu quero sentar aqui
e saiba tudo
não sei se já passou minuto mas eu acho
que já deu pra passar a ideia de um
século não só no século nós cantamos
como também um certo que não chega a
todos os dias
o que nós vemos aqui é para mim um só
que isto é bom já imagina para um toque
ficou doente está maluca qualquer coisa
mais fácil pra mim não sei que é isso
e de repente expressa aquilo dig
diagramas fashion que achou de partilha
no facebook tudo mas tentei foi feito
propositadamente para isso
o texto é um exercício do design feito
por estudantes por arquitetos muito
crível estando por um grupo 2 da rede
que instiga arquitetura por que pensar
no séc
não é só aquela confusão que nós vimos a
bancada mas é também não se estava a
passar eu acho traz também não é só o
canto é e todas aquelas imagens páginas
de um jornal
cazenga os acessos atrapalham senso júri
da cunha - um gueto é também um certo
para mim traduzido não é acaba por ser
esta imagem
ora bem o quê que esta imagem vocês
podem perguntar
portanto esta imagem a partida vocês vêm
palavras vêm letras v em cortes mas ela
tem uma relação de escalas que é
importante compreender a partida
anulei aqui algumas imagens tanto nós
temos 17 temos ali a escala maior
logo a seguir a palavra mulher que a
palavra sustentabilidade
então faça um exercício porque isto é
mesmo brainstorm não é esta esta tem
estado de celebrar o que nós vamos fazer
aqui um caso para conseguir explicar
qual é o desafio que o estrago
então um século depois de retirarmos no
mundo de palavras que você já não se
lembram a paixão é sustentabilidade
logo a seguir tem quatro dimensões
porque a escala das letras é melhor
então aquilo que eu considero ser a
sustentabilidade ela tem quatro
dimensões
econômica cultural e social está lá na e
cada uma delas pela sua relação de cores
acaba também por fazer parte de outros
objetos de outras idéias e outros
conceitos que também não parece tão
organizados
nós nunca naturalmente podemos olhar
para um objeto olhar para um espaço
urbano mas ainda eu como arquiteta
investigadora professora há respostas
que às vezes é preciso dar e para nós
darmos respostas temos também que saber
construídas né
então a questão da sustentabilidade é
uma palavra tremendo imagem com o admiro
tem a imensa se imenso sucesso explicar
que a sustentabilidade ambiental ea
sustentabilidade financeira
provavelmente deve existir aqui
bancários esta esta população você vê
que estou muito diverso então
sustentabilidade para cada um de nós tem
uma tem uma expressão não é para o
trabalho que eu faço instante a
sustentabilidade é multidimensional
naturalmente e é vista na versão
econômica cultural social e ambiental
e este sistema de palavras chaves para
além de se organizar no campo ambiental
também se organiza no campo da
urbanidade e no campo da urbanidade ela
já tem mais cara de arquitetura então aí
nós estamos a falar de equipamento de
habitação de sistema viário de espaços
verdes e cada um também se vai
desdobrando num conjunto de outras
palavras que associadas pela cor vos vão
dar então a idéia da dimensional idade
não sair tanto estudou ok já
compreendemos a cor da sustentabilidade
a urbanidade está aquele com o outro mas
o que que esta treta não é tanto que que
é esta este este mapa esta neste
conjunto de palavras chave serve o
propósito de nós entrarmos estuda maio a
suportar
aqui está uma ferramenta que nós
utilizamos aí que estamos a utilizar mas
também porque estão processo que
investiga se há um longo e é um processo
é uma ferramenta que nós utilizamos para
trabalhar a análise crítica aos espaços
de um século na cidade de luanda
portanto aquilo que nós há bocado olhar
luxo não é que era uma série de jornais
chá música aquelas letras todas tudo
isto aquele mapa que pode parecer uma
chef 14 bonitas como sexo que tal feito
é uma ferramenta de trabalho como é que
ela funciona
vamos dar um exemplo se isolar todas as
letras e fui escolher por exemplo o
elemento cultural eu vou encontrar aqui
cultura e suas culturas foram as
palavras que nós resolvemos escolher e
elas estão sempre em constante mutação
portanto está o processo de naves
crítica que não é restritivo neca dizer
essa coisa de que somos assim temos que
ir assim até o fim
não fica muito bem com o tom de pele não
é o número que eu visto portanto estas
palavras pode ser que venham a mudar
daqui uns tempos mas sofá
aquilo que nós temos cada vez que vamos
analisar um século do ponto de vista
cultural e eliminando todos os outros
elementos eu encontro a questão das
culturas deixando culturas bom aqui esta
frase porque a cidade é o cenário e quem
é fácil eu acho que a fazem ser a minha
tarde
ei eu nem quero parabéns porque que eu
entro neste pormenor porque a dimensão
cultural está diretamente ligada às
pessoas ea cidade o espaço urbano espaço
construído não é nada sem elas
e quando nós falamos de um século nós
estamos a falar obrigatoriamente de uma
realidade holandês
estamos a falar de um conceito de luanda
estamos a falar de um vocábulo que sai
das línguas que falo em luanda
portanto um século não é de benguela é
de uma laje não é de lisboa não é do
brasil não se quer luandense na china e
criado desde o século 16
aqui se depois nós vamos através
aí vamos globalizar o conceito e só aí
já é segunda parte da história mas a
partida 17 é uma realidade de luanda não
vai não vou explicar o porquê tudo mais
mas se o sexo é uma realidade de luanda
então este que a fazem ser os
personagens que fazem parte do dono seko
então são personagens de luanda e vamos
buscar então aqueles que são os
personagens mais antigos e apetece me
buscar o mais polêmico de todos
principalmente nos últimos tempos a
marca com engenheiros têm dado um
passado todo o tamanho
e resumindo e concluindo com nós olhamos
para as mulheres vivemos aquela imagem
está lá em cima
nós olhamos com alguma distância e tudo
mais na rua atrapalharam se queremos que
as páginas todas as húngaras deve ser
dos personagens mais antigos da
urbanidade em angola portanto a partir
do momento em que se constituísse
criança cidadã holanda que é a mais
antiga pelo menos de influência européia
no nosso território naturalmente surgem
alto e surge aí uma simbiose entre
aquilo que são as vivências o peso das
vendas africanas e naturalmente a ação
do comercial ao ar livre é mesmo nossa e
nós e não no sentido angola luanda mas
nossa africana até por uma questão do
clima
por uma questão de relações sociais e
quero vocês estejam em marrocos quer
estejam em luanda vocês vão encontrar o
vender ao ar livre
portanto é uma maneira de estar tão
gitman quanto qualquer outra mas no
entanto nós rejeitamos surpreendente
mental e uma imagem que tudo vai ser
implementada mas porque que aquela
imagem do canto inferior direito estava
ia fazer
alguém conhece na outra vez carmen
miranda
olha que eu saiba é mais famosas um
ngueira do ouro barriga fora não dá pra
levantar a coisa que mais agrava a roupa
está curta né
balaio na cabeça fruta sacou das carnes
mel importante xinguila e o que ela faz
o que é que a baiana tem
o que é que a baiana tem mais cada vez
que nós estamos em casa eu vim buscar a
paz
ela é lá estão é estado a sujar a rua e
esta o que se passa connosco que de
repente não é batemos palmas e como
humanidade até damos um ótica da carmen
miranda e no entanto chama de repente
que as mangueiras é um mal é uma coisa
errada e mesmo quando contrariamos esta
noção que está a espalhar do que há um
ano de crise um gay é o mal
nós não sabemos muito bem porque é um
mal ou porque que vem aumentando bem mas
aqui pronto de uma forma muito clara
porque januário vai matar não é mas eu
disse que eu poderia até 30 minutos
portanto youtube
mas brincadeiras à parte importante isto
é para trazer a ideia dos personagens
constroem cidade pra mim das guerras nós
temos muitos outros
temos roteiros temos enfim temos uma
série de hoje estamos a falar daquilo
que está em búzios no sexo ok é para não
ficar só no exemplo trouxe um segundo
que é depois a dimensão econômica quando
estamos a falar de dimensão econômica
então aí interessa perceber o musseque
quer do ponto de vista do emprego
autoemprego fundamentalmente mas
principalmente o valor do musseque que
eu acho que nunca ninguém parou para
pensar no valor de um século
parabéns tudo que nós fazemos bairro
operário todo mundo conhece portanto um
século de malha regular do frio economia
o primeiro quero ser um projeto de
urbanização para ficar direitinho na
época essa coisa de do ator não funciona
muito bem talvez mesmo em seguida em
alfama seja bom ter duas portas mais um
ano vamos endireitar estão os retos e
tudo mais que a coisa funcionar bom
resumindo e concluindo a idéia do bairro
prato de nós conhecemos pela componente
histórica porque mandei preparar um feto
não sei que é mesmo bairro para né
quando nós olhamos para um sexo do
bairro operário nós nunca nos
perguntamos por que de repente um colega
meu arquiteto no encontro de vela no
workshop diz olha desculpas às duas
coisas métricas de um sexo e tudo mais
mas um bairro operário não é rentável
isto porque
matemática aquela básica vulgar de mel
portanto tem uma área de 200 mil e 300
mil metros quadrados o valor atual é a
segunda que o que nós fizemos um
levantamento com alguns agentes
imobiliários é de cerca de 1000 euros
por metro quadrado porque é um espaço
está degradada time tá mas e que vai dar
mais ou menos uns 300 milhões de dólares
pelo espaço mas com intervenção ea
valorização imobiliária 7 sobe até 3
bilhões de dólares e o mais engraçado é
que isto é um retorno em cinco anos
é óbvio que aquelas focas todas têm que
sair dali epá não é rentável
vamos dar umas casas não no panguila no
zango que só mais uma informação zinha
básica estão fora da fronteira da cidade
luanda a não mais curta já estou até
receber uma casa melhor mas a casa é
fora mesmo do território de luanda e por
aí em diante para fazer o quê nem tab
lizar o bairro operário surpreendente
momento bairro operário tem exatamente a
mesma dimensão consoleto alguém já ouviu
dizer que você vai responsabilizar os 8
não porque será num cinema scala nós
temos abordagens diferentes sobre os
passos e importância que os pais têm
portanto a questão do valor não é uma
forma como se utilizam essas ferramentas
o que meu tempo acabou
as formas como se utilizam essas
ferramentas é tem que ter algum
propósito eo propósito tem a ver com
esta abordagem patrimonial a estes
passos na cidade de luanda porque nós
consideramos ou julgamos é em termos de
investigação que um cep é uma componente
tem um elemento patrimonial
as nações unidas ea shows lá sua
inteligente nessa estreia segunda carla
é dizem treinar os lamas na hora de
porcarias é exatamente o livro great de
blá blá blá blá blá a áreas da cidade em
pleno inverno e eficientes e night mexam
em 2006
ninguém pode contrariar isso eu não
estou de acordo portanto não vai já no
carinho mesmo provar isso alguém
eventualmente
tiver outra ideia vamos sentar gosto de
papo não há nada melhor do que isso
vamos ver quem convence mudar o outro eu
sei que eu vou ganhar mas pronto
o facto é que o clube sexo surpreendente
momento não é uma zona não planificada
existem do período pós propósito não é
no período pós independência ela passa a
ser espontânea mas ela é autocrática é
aquilo que se chama arquitetura
arquitetura sem arquitete obedece a
outro tipo de projectos e por aí antes
tanto nós temos aqui depois também
alguma leitura mais a escala menor
daquilo que há um certo portanto temos
uma componente muito pessoal das pessoas
daquilo que é a cultura de um sexo do
canto de um séquito tudo mais e temos
depois também uma outra vertente que é a
vertente física acaba como shoppings já
percebemos em berlim viu e que de fato
tem um elemento que está degradado mas
puro comparação mês crise é como ter um
dente cariado ou a gente limpa etapa
portanto trata dentro a gente arranque
foi uma prótese
eu não gosto muito própria coisa acho
que não vai funcionar muito comigo mas é
uma questão da abordagem e com isto a
ideia que os trazia era esta não é de 1
vou explicar o que é isso do musseque e
porque que era importante fazer esta
leitura patrimonial musseque e do
espécime desta forma e aproveitando não
para um bingo
olha a cantar e até